welcome to bananamores if you don't know
this next comedian yet you're about to
have your mind blown
give it up for one of my favorites sam
taggart
wow hello um it is uh
simply incredible to be at banana morris
today i'm thrilled
um you know it is kind of a weird time
to be like
um recording this because um currently
to the day it is uh the one year
anniversary of lockdown
and you know it kind of begs for
reflection
and normally you know i i don't really
like to self-reflect i
i think it's kind of problematic because
what if i see my own flaws
no thank you um but it's a special
occasion so
when in rome um so a year ago
today i was actually doing something
kind of exciting
i was um emily in paris which is what i
call
working temporarily in a foreign country
and rudely and almost on purposely
not using the language at all
you know it wasn't exactly paris um i
was in
the paris of south america which is
santiago chile
at this point cobid was like you know
it's in the news you're hearing about it
but it kind of feels like
well that's not for me like it's kind of
like cavities where it's like
yeah other people get those because
they're like not good people like i'm
really really nice
so i'm not gonna get that but thank you
so
i'm in chile for work and i'm you know
during the days oh i'm working so hard
i'm working with an incredible team of
people
it's hello it's great job it's awesome
work we're working
and then you know at night well i'm in a
foreign country so it's
let's go to a restaurant let's go to a
bar let's go to a discoteca
why not i'm again you know i'm living it
up
and honestly it was lovely or as emily
and paris would say
it was lovely she never learned the
language she only speaks english even
like a full
season in it's kind of crazy but anyway
about four days into this
um lovely journey i get the call that
almost every writer performer actor begs
for
it is the call
from the hr department of a giant media
conglomerate
and i pick up the phone and i'm like
yes this is he and they're like um
yeah hi um this is regarding your recent
audition
and i'm like this is gigantic i'm about
to blow up i'm about to pop all the way
off and they're like yeah so the person
running that audition
um actually did have kovid so you have
been exposed
um yeah so have a good day
and i tried to ask a question and she
quickly got off the phone presumably to
tell
25 other men who look and sound almost
exactly like me
but some slightly hotter and some
slightly less hot that they were also
exposed
so i'm in my hotel room and i'm just
like
freaking out because it's like wait i
could have this thing i could have covid
and that's like wait if i can have covet
that means i can get like cavities too
like
this is so messed up like my entire
world view is crumbling
and then like i can't even think about
the cavities because i'm realizing like
oh my god
everyone that i've interacted with if i
have it
has also been exposed and i'm like
running through each delightful little
person i've met and it's like
even if we're just counting the elderly
it's like way more people than you would
expect
and so i'm fully freaking out and i'm
like okay it's not a huge deal it's not
a huge deal like
maybe if you just like maybe it's
already rampant in chile
in this situation that would be a good
thing because you know i wouldn't be
making a huge splash
so i look up how many people in chile
currently have covet
and at that point it was 10. 10 people
had it
and so now i'm like okay not only do i
have it
potentially but i've maybe doubled or
tripled the amount of people that have
been exposed in the entire nation of
chile
that's bad like i'm gonna be like the
face of
evil for generations to come i'm gonna
be in like
kids stories about like evil people
it's insane i'm gonna be like what the
zebra muscle is to the great lakes
region or
what dr phil is to oprah's legacy or i
don't know what emily is to parisians
who hate american tourists
i'm freaking out i'm freaking out i'm
freaking out eventually
i managed to get a test because well i
know people
yeah i can get a test if i want to get
over it
and it comes back negative
all good i'm totally fine
i breathe a sigh of relief and then i
just
safely go back to new york and spend
basically the rest of the year
in my apartment but you know
i've got a feeling that just like emily
and paris season two
i'll be coming out soon too and even
though everyone's like no we're good
you don't really want you can stay i'll
be coming out soon people may be like no
no thank you but i'll be coming up
no no i'm good you can stay in your
apartment but i'm coming out soon it's
always emily in paris too
thank you so much i've been sam
does it get any better than this guy i
literally did not stop
laughing the whole time sam performed